all right there's no more hole guys we
got ourselves a dc leak of super pets
batman trailer they're riding that
batman wave they're the only ones on the
internet doing that right now and it got
spoiled for us who's playing batman
keanu reeves i actually watched the
trailer for the first time a couple days
ago when prepping that other video about
every batman project coming up and i was
like this one looks good
what are we watching
all right guys if you're here leave a
like we are shooting this before our
live stream spoiler talk i'm assuming it
went splendid definitely going up after
it because we don't have time to edit
because koi has a heart out that's why
we're doing this one by ourselves let's
go
[Music]
you are a dog
i am the batman
yeah i'm not really great with people
probably because of my traumatic
puppyhood that's a child
[Laughter]
you literally worship the ground that
dude walks on technically he flies
batman works alone except for robin and
alfred commissioner gordon
t crew whoever morgan freeman played
what do i have here
squeezy what
i want a squeezy bruise
toy or i will freak out
[Music]
oh man there's some meta humor for you
because everyone's gonna be buying that
squeezy batman well they can't have the
lego movie franchise right now that went
to universal recently discovered yeah
you know it's funny like when uh when i
was doing the video the other day they
put up i read off like the plot
description and batman wasn't even like
mentioning there so i thought it was
just gonna be like some quick cameo that
you get a batman in it that'd be more
superman centric i mean with crypto of
the superdog of course while the first
trailer really leaned heavily into that
looks like we're actually going to be
getting a good amount of batman as i'm
assuming they waited to unveil that
because of the massive 128 million
dollar successful opening weekend that
they had yeah i mean keanu reeves doing
the voiceover work for it i think he's
like perfect for these kind of voice
over performances like who we played in
toy story 4 was hilarious remember who
that character's name is duke kaboom
yep andrew gave me one i got a couple
others i was honored to be associated
with the character i love like the humor
here because it does feel reminiscent of
the lego movie franchise and with a lot
of it's like meta ways and also it seems
like this is what they can do to sort of
get some of that cool comic book stylish
influence that like things such as
across the spider verse have been able
to infuse with their animation also like
that meta self-awareness angle like if
you can't have the lego batman movie
anymore maybe they can do this like you
could totally see if this pans out that
you can get a spin-off with keanu reeves
in the role of batman and having this
like humorous metaphorical connection
between what a lone dog and a batman is
like i think it's really funny i thought
that was great yeah yeah one i don't
know to me you said that thing about
like not knowing that we'd get quite as
much batman or at least seeming as
though like batman would be as prominent
of characters superman in this but it
makes me wonder like that the rest of
the pets maybe that will be we'll get
kind of a bit between each of them and
their super
respective owner etc and then you know
get the ensemble bit of all the pets
we'll probably see some of the
superheroes and right it just seems like
there's so much potential for so much
fun to be had across this and i mean
yeah keanu reeves the combination of the
animation and the stylization they go
with with his voiceover and like batman
is already a meme and like we have will
our nets yeah like meme-ish portrayal
and i love that this is also in that
lane but it's not exactly that it's not
the same a batman it's definitely like
the the circa keanu reeves vibe
obviously because he brings a certain
amount of himself wherever he goes and i
would love love love to see more
animated stuff with him in the role just
because i mean at this point he is
getting to that point where he could be
you know he's such a badass and he's an
elder statesman but also he's got that
dark side yeah i just think that's so
wonderful well i think what's cool about
when you do batman in these movies is
like you have the films like live action
you've had like the ben afflecks you've
had now robert pattinson when you do
that they make them so grim and so dark
and then when they go animated they use
that opportunity to really poke fun at
itself and that's something i think
warner brothers has a pretty good handle
on balancing out like it's strangely not
bizarre at all to have your darkest
batman movie come out and then a couple
days later release this trailer and be
perfectly amused and not feel like it's
too much it's this weird ace in the hole
that they got with the batman where they
can just use whatever they want to do
with them and it seems to always work oh
and they waited till today till sunday
so they wouldn't overshadow robert
pattinson yeah
his conversation about the character but
this movie just looks like a lot of fun
in general you know i know we haven't
really shared our thoughts on it but i i
like dwayne johnson in the voiceover
role for crypto john krasinski is
superman and then of course you have
kevin hart in here and kevin hart i
think can play off of anyone and i
wonder if this was the kind of movie in
the sense that they really let them be
in the same booth together because
usually if they're not in the same booth
you can kind of tell but when they are
you get this certain kind of back and
forth and rapport that just is great and
i think the animation style feeling very
like classic dc almost like the early
days of detective comics is kind of the
flair that you get with it sort of that
like 1950s type of animation style to it
yeah with some exaggeration like i love
how sort of like bulky and top heavy
batman is and like how tall his ears are
and things like that like yeah it's very
heightened and very stylized in a way
that suits also like 3d animation and
kind of makes it distinct from the 2d
stuff that we're used to seeing the one
thing though that i'm getting a little
bit tired of with warner brothers is it
seems like their most common joke is to
make fun of warner brothers they love to
reference themselves yeah
and all their various properties that's
the one thing where i'm like okay all
right you got this one joke that you
seem to be carrying through all your
comedy franchises here now yes
self-deprecation can be fun yes
can't be a way to endear people to you
after a while you're like alright let's
dial it back now all right guys it's
it's even though it makes me laugh every
day every freaking trailer i'm like it's
so funny well you know it's the spectrum
now is it the matrix resurrection sorry
you know dc super pet all right guys
what did you think about this trailer
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
last but not least let's do it
i want to shout out today tyler hey you
message me on twitter saying you saw the
batman and that you really dug it what i
want to say to you though is is that if
i was a dog i'd want you to be my owner
you'd be scratching my chin
rubbing my belly forcing me to sleep on
the edge of your bed
while you sleep in the nude and as your
dog
i'd watch you
i'd have the consciousness of a human
being but not be able to communicate it
to you
verbally due to the fact i am in dog
form but i'd be watching you every step
of the way tongue out
panting heavily
you are so gross
don't deny my rust
i was just thinking of tyler boy that is
not you uh i i was i was getting turned
on until i saw my peripheral
oh god
tyler this went from sexual to being
cancer to the extra sexual anyway kids
hope you got this shout out on dc league
of super pets
you